um I actually think that
you know I've always felt like team
ninja has good Concepts but they never
execute anything well you know it's
always like they're always
want things short and they all their
games you know is this game
on this calibers like a from software
game I would actually say yeah well it's
definitely not the like sakuro and Eldon
ring but I think this is one of the
first games I've seen team ninja do
where I could see I could definitely see
them getting to that point eventually as
long as they're nurtured correctly they
learn from their mistakes I could see
Tim ninja delivering just as good games
as from software but the problem is is
you know they always miss miss something
big and I feel like
they try to they try to be too much like
sekro but didn't do anything that that
was better than Sakura like you know
they the